only a politician as out of touch with
reality as Donald Trump could claim this
week's midterm elections in the US were
a tremendous success given that his
party lost control of the House of
Representatives and that the young women
and ethnic minority voters came out
significantly against him
it's a typical Trump statement ignore
the facts claim what you want and hey
presto it's true but no one should
assume that this means Trump won't win
again in two years time Ronald Reagan
Bill Clinton and Barack Obama
all do badly at them in terms in their
first term and went on to win a second
presidential election having said that I
do think there's a good chance Trump
will be a one-term president and that's
something we should all welcome we all
know he's a misogynist and a racist
even his own lawyers who quite rates him
said the real problem with Trump is that
he's an effing liar we can only hope
these elections show the tide is turning
against Trump for good Gregg just before
I challenge you let's tell you where we
find ourselves at the time of taping of
this show to the house where the damn
we're listening we're looking for 218
for the majority the Democrats already
posting 222 Republicans 199 so you're
right the house goes to the Democrats
but in the Senate again at the time of
recording the Democrats 46 the
Republicans 51 so mr. Trump will
obviously retain that I I think if this
is what intrigues me people like you and
many people despise him intently I
wonder if there's been such a reviled
president in recent years you would have
thought then when this opportunity came
a nation the size of America was
thirsting to give him at least a bloody
nose of something not even more painful
for the bloke because he's so out of
touch with reality
well the reality is they didn't they
didn't and in fact if you look as we
said at the Senate he retains control
there there wasn't the blue wave that
Hollywood said would be coming that way
it was I give it yes it was a good night
for the Democrats but at best it's a
score draw both sides can claim they
actually have victory and if he is such
a bad president I'm staggered
staggered he had anything to talk about
the morning after I think scourge was
wrong I don't think it was a six nil
that's for sure to the Democrats but if
you actually look at the the figures the
Democrats got eight percent more votes
out people voting Democrat than voting
Republican if nothing happened and what
you've got to do is compare the House of
Representatives because that was last
elected two years ago whereas the Senate
was six years ago in a different time
but so so it to be Goebbels meets Pol
Pot isn't either way you pay well how
come he's didn't know we like we know
there's a base we know he's got a base
we know that that that base will turn
out for him as it did he he campaigned
much harder to be fluid than any other
peep US president in my lifetime grant
you that he obviously loves campaigning
that's what he likes doing he loves
those those around his and things where
he personally got involved with the
campaign Ted Cruz's result you know
there was a real surge because his
support base it's so strong first his
places that he didn't if the public is
to have lost Texas they did expect a
blow with its Democrats really thought
this was gonna be the time for a country
being run by a maniac to look at the
mirror see what was then say we're gonna
get rid of this but they didn't do that
and you know what in it is not unusual
to lose seats in the House of
Representatives but it is unusual to
gain seats in the Senate and they think
he has actually gains his I mean you you
mentioned 51 they think it could be as
many as 54 so he's gay he will have
games three which is incredible which
will underline for Trump that his base
is telling him that everything he's done
is okay yeah but they're not when you're
looking at the Senate you're not
comparing this election with two years
ago when he got elected you comparing
the six years ago says well my spirit is
with you Greg but my head is not because
the comparison here would be Obama in
his first term lost 63 House seats yet
Clinton in his first term midterm lost
52 I think the problem that people like
you and me who are in the same place as
Trump have is that actually we may be
the ones who are out of touch with
reality he's actually winning and the
big thing that came out of the elections
I think is not the number
it is that he now has complete control
and loyalty of the Republican Party up
until now one of the his weaknesses is
that his own party didn't like him now
they don't like him anymore now but they
know that they have a winner and they
will line up behind him in 2020 and I
frankly can't find it hard to see how
can it be beaten because a Democrat a
that have a candidate that's right and
Dorine which is one of the reasons they
got they didn't do well this time
I mean wine could just be wishful
thinking so having lost the house means
that it's gonna be harder for him to
drive through a lot of his agenda now I
mean I can't do this exactly he would
use the house represented as an excuse
for everything which is breaking all
records now if that goes down which the
predictions are Eddie's gonna it is
gonna start failing he can blame he can
blame the house representatives for that
because he's saying you're in charge
there's no national Trump has a
narrative we like his narrative has
worked him we know that but I think
what's really interesting to look at and
I think you're right I mean i agree with
you trevor that i think there's a danger
for us to do this kind of wishful
thinking exercise which we can't
understand why not vote for him and then
we interpret anything that shows other
people don't like him as their kind of
move in a direction that's my people i
know i cerebral I understand it Carol I
just can't personally relate to it but I
completely understand what's going on I
think that it's interesting to look at
some of the trends so for example yes
you know he gained seats and he didn't
lose as many in the house as some people
thought he would but it's interesting
how the split is happening how some
Republican areas in suburbs have moved
towards Democrat how the rural urban
divide is really opening up and I think
that is going to be an interesting trend
looking at the next lecture because he's
dividing people in different ways you
know he clearly has a very strong
support but it's not traditional and I
just want to add as well about about the
some of the the first that were achieved
in this election you know a record
number of women of minority women LGBTQ
for the first time Native American women
being elected to the legislature and I
just want to show you one of my favorite
new elected Democrats illa Hanna Omar
because she is such an inspiring
character
and as we fight to protect our immigrant
families our neighbors our children our
planet our communities I promise to
always have your back so for the first
time we have a Somali American who
immigrated to the you to the US as a
teenager being elected and I think that
shows the split that's happening you
know that someone like her would not
have got elected 10 15 years ago
attention from all of that at the end of
yesterday and Saxbys Attorney General so
this is this is the genius of Trump a
few laughs I will put my money where our
mouth is I will take 20 pounds with each
of you that actually probably not me
next time something else as well but
I'll tell you owe me for that one
because I think the key points here are
as I think Trevor I heard you agree this
is such a great narrative for him come
the next direction because you can just
point to the table he's not been able to
get anything through and the other key
which I think carries you name me the
Democrat who's emerged that can beat him
but you couldn't name Trump two years
before the election possibly but how
he's treating journalists since his
election results this is a good example
with when the name Trump comes up
everybody fooled into tribe tribal
position here's what happened at this
press conference and I talked about
reaction honestly I think you should let
me run the country you run CNN or and if
you did it well your ratings let me ask
mr. president that said now pardon me
ma'am
miss me that's enough that's enough put
down the mic mr. president are you
worried about indictments coming down
mr. president I'll tell what CNN should
be ashamed of itself having you working
for them you are a rude terrible person
you shouldn't be working for CNN go
ahead see the media is now saying oh
look at what he did actually the truth
of the matter is Jim Acosta they've had
a longtime spat Acosta broke the rules
of the press conference he should have
had a question and a follow-up and he
would not surrender the microphone and
Trump who is a boy and a Vulgarian was
actually in the right here that's our
problem we cannot get past our dislike
of shrunk to deal with things from
America matters to those that affect the
entire world this is the part of the
show when we'd normally laugh at
something or someone who's done or said
something silly but for once we're going
to be a lot more serious this weekend
marks the centenary at the end of the
first world war a conflict that took the
lives of 17 million people this special
anniversary is being marked across the
country and indeed the world including
at the Tower of London where 10,000
torches are being lit every night this
week in a tribute known as beyond the
deepening shadow so this week we'll
leave you with words you may well be
familiar with worse than not of our own
but which express our mood better than
we ever could they shall grow not old as
we that are left grow old age shall not
weary them nor the years condemn the
going down of the Sun and in the morning
we will remember them